[Music]
mazie to see you look gorgeous
let's talk about the showstopper at the
end come on I mean it seemed like you
were kind of overcome with some emotion
what was like having a front-row seat to
that I literally was like this I was in
awe and it's funny because scientists
have actually stated that the the state
of awe is like the most blissful state
you could be in and that's what she put
me in she was as she put me in the state
of awe she's timeless she is she's I
said it on stage but she's an icon at 10
years old
helping pave the way for many artists to
come that's so cool about this show in
particular because literally is so
inclusive you have young people like
Eamon I do want to get your thoughts on
Lara Spencer and her reaction to a young
boy in this case Prince George taking
ballet classes I mean as a dancer
someone who was raised with a fellow
male dancer what did you make of that
you know I think everything happens for
a reason I think that that comment
sparked an amazing resurgence and
passion for dancers to to have a voice
you know dancers have always been in the
background and so for for those comments
to be made it it gave dancers a voice to
show the dedication the hard work and
the perseverance that it takes to become
a dancer and then I also think it gave
humanity and the world in the country an
opportunity to also let somebody
apologize for something and see it for
what it is
versus just saying that's it and I'm
gonna forever think of you that way and
I thought it was beautiful
that they had a conversation and you
know I think it's just David my brother
actually said it beautifully it's like
you know sometimes you just aren't
educated or it's not your world and so
you're not in it and
so you're not connected to it but now
now I think she's connected to it I love
Laura and I and I don't think that that
was a malicious thing that she intended
to do I think it was something that was
unfortunate and now it's it's been an
amazing opportunity for dancers to step
out and speak up and have it have a
moment which I think is really important
but I'm really very proud of the dance
community that they didn't take this and
then just like shun or divide and
separate or cancel or cancel because
that's what the world is lacking is
understanding and education and I think
that it was handled so beautifully so
I'm so proud it like makes me emotional
because I'm so proud to be a part of the
dance community that that's how we
handled it versus just shunning people
away because it was a teachable moment
for the whole world and like you
mentioned you are in it you are
connected to it I mean growing up did
you see your brother or kind of be
exposed that kind of bullying absolutely
and I think that that was the whole
thing it really triggered people because
of bullying that had happened to them
and so of course we're gonna be we're
gonna be defensive automatically when
that happens because we know what it did
for us and it most of the time dance
saved our lives you know it gave us an
outlet of expression so dance is one of
the most important things that have has
saved my life in many ways and so to be
able to have this kind of exposure
unfortunately under the braid of someone
but but it's turned around and everyone
is now inclusive and I think that that
is the message here is that we're just
accepting a mom
[Music]
you